we begin this morning with breaking news
overnight of several large wildfires
burning across the West compounded by
that brutal heatwave one of the most
devastating fires is in the hills above
Goleta California near Santa Barbara the
fast-moving wind driven blaze began last
night destroying at least 20 homes and
threatening several other buildings more
than 2,000 people were forced to
evacuate the fire advanced to about a
mile from the business district Carter
Evans is in Goleta Carter good morning
good morning when this fire started late
last night it moved through here
extremely fast driven by winds gusting
up to 40 miles per hour you can see this
home on fire right now there is really
nothing firefighters can do will tilt up
the camera a little bit and you can see
those embers flying through the air
that is the problem these wind driven
flames are blowing embers throughout the
community of Goleta and some of those
embers have landed on the rooftops of
homes like this one the fire moved so
fast that firefighters could barely keep
up with it again it started late in the
evening so their focus initially was
evacuating people from their homes take
a look at this home there's really
nothing left inside in all about 1200
people were evacuated from this
community and they had to leave at a
moment's notice they were not expecting
to have to evacuate tonight although
they knew this was possible we've been
experiencing these triple digit
temperatures for the last day or so in
Southern California you add to that the
dry brush and these are perfect
conditions for a fire just like this one
now it's unclear exactly how many homes
have burned right now it's looking like
at least 20 firefighters still don't
have a cause on this fire as for the hot
dry weather that should continue through
Saturday and possibly have some relief
on Sunday Errol alright called Evans
thank you for that close-up look there
in Goleta California